bonsoir thierry mariani merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france me
libre me confiner ou confinés à
l'extérieur on ne sait pas trop si les
français d'ailleurs ne savent pas bien
ce que c'est il est évident qu'ils en
ont assez
la lassitude le pire ennemi du
gouvernement on a vu dans votre région
d'ailleurs un paca notamment à marseille
la lassitude et puis l'incompréhension
devant toute une série de mesures qui
sont qui partent dans tous les sens le
meilleur exemple c'est ce qui s'est
passé avec les attestations ou vous avez
vu d'abord on a eu une première
attestation puis une deuxième
attestation puis les français savent
plus quoi remplir
là je suis à bruxelles j'ai dû à la gare
les français savent plus quel papier
montrer excusez moi cette boutade mais
la bureaucratie soviétique a disparu il
ya 30 ans mais macro et entraîne de la
reconstituer en france à l'occasion de
cette crise et puis tout ça n'a aucun
sens je veux dire désormais c'est quoi
c'est une attestation pour que les
français s'autorise même à sortir en
sachant très bien que en réalité les
adresses qui sont données souvent sont
des adresses symbolique donc les clés
francillon dépression quand les emmerdes
qu'on leur fait pas confiance et je
pense que c'est ça qui les agace de plus
en plus c'est à dire qu'à côté d'une
minorité extrême minorité qui ne
respectent pas les mesures de sécurité
on l'a vu effectivement hier à marseille
à ce carnaval qui est également
organisée par des organisations appelant
le d'extrême gauche là l'écrasante
majorité des français sont certes mais
le demandent qu'on les prenne au sérieux
qu'on ne les prenne plus pour des
enfants et qu'on arrête de leur faire
remplir des pieds des 1000 sérieux mais
quand même un peu déprimé d'ailleurs il
y avait une réunion autour de cela
apparemment emmanuel macron nous dit on
est très préoccupée par le le moral des
français
doit-on craindre selon vous en effet
cocotte minute
on voit des gens qui à quelques
manifestations ici ou là notamment en
allemagne
bah écoutez c'est vrai que pour certains
français à ça devient totalement
insupportable
je pense aux jeunes en particulier vous
savez j'ai rencontré un certain nombre
d'étudiants pendant le week-end
quand vous êtes étudiant à paris par
exemple que vous payez pour
vous payez à peine une chambre de 12
mètres carrés que vous êtes quasiment
confinés à l'intérieur sans pouvoir
sortir à part dans la journée mais où le
soir vous devez rester sans voir
personne
et puis je pense aussi excusez-moi aux
commerçants parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est
quand même 90 mille commerçants dans ses
seize départements qui sont fermées avec
des aberrations les coiffeurs sont
ouverts mais pas les esthéticiennes
franchement les esthéticiennes sont
aussi responsables que les coiffeurs
elles sont capables d'appliquer des
gestes de protocole vous avez des séries
de profession par exemple je vous
prendre les chaussures alors aujourd'hui
pouvaient plus acheter vos chaussures
dans un magasin mais vous pouvez les
acheter sur amazon et puis alors si vous
êtes dans ma région
si vous allez sur ce qu'on appelle les
marchés de provence en plein air vous
pouvez les acheter sur les marchés tout
ça manque de logique manque de cohérence
et et c'est vrai que tout cela finit par
saouler les français mais qu'est ce
qu'on aurait dû faire
thierry mariani confiné de manière
stricte fermé absolument tout comme en
mars dernier qu'elle était la lame ou
moins pire des solutions si j'ose dire
le pen a demandé depuis le début c'est à
dire depuis le début de la crise marine
le pen a dit très clairement deux choses
1 fermeture des frontières et de
déconfinement par région fermeture des
frontières monsieur macron a refusé
souvenez-vous au début il disait mon dos
mon dieu c'est les nationalistes qui
demande ça c'est horrible on voit
aujourd'hui par exemple toute une série
de pays européens ont pris les mesures
identiques
l'allemagne est finalement on a bien vu
il ya quelques mois que lui-même a dû
reconnaître qu'il fallait fermer les
frontières entre temps que de temps
perdu et ses deuxièmes balles trop tard
ou donc aujourd'hui c'est trop tard
parce qu'effectivement messieurs macro
on n'a pas voulu prendre les mesures
appropriées
ensuite sur le confinement par région
oui ça c'est la bonne solution mais il
faut aussi dans ce cas là que ce soit
j'allais dire gagnant gagnant pour ceux
qui qui sont beaucoup moins de toucher
qu'est ce que je veux dire par là
je prends un exemple en par exemple la
région parisienne est extrêmement
touchée effectivement elle est confinée
mais par exemple la bretagne ou
l'occitanie sont beaucoup moins touchés
pourquoi pas dire dans ces régions là on
commence à réouvrir par exemple les
terrasses puisqu'on nous explique qu'en
plein air
c'est beaucoup moins dangereux voyez je
veux dire il faut donner de l'espoir aux
gens il faut que dans les régions où le
virus circule beaucoup moins eh bien on
puisse libérer des soupapes pour les
commerçants je pense bien sûr au café
parce que vous connaissez la mentalité
française les terrasses en france c'est
ça fait presque partie du patrimoine et
du moral des français
voilà pourquoi par exemple on n'autorise
pas dans ces régions où le co vide à une
circulation beaucoup plus réduite
certains cafés à réouvrir où certains
restaurants à réouvrir pourquoi par
exemple alors que le gouvernement m a
enfin reconnu qu'en se confient les
moins à l'extérieur qu'à l'intérieur
après avoir traqué les français qui
étaient sur les plages dans les forêts
dans les montagnes
aujourd'hui on dit pas pour les derniers
jours qui restent aux stations de ski
vous pouvez ouvrir
voilà et on a l'impression qu'en réalité
il ya une stratégie uniquement punitive
il ya des endroits où la circuit la
situation est meilleure et puis il faut
que cette situation soit reconnue et qui
à l'assouplissement et puis enfin vous
cette nuit on est ce qu'il n'ya et puis
enfin si vous le permettez en sortira de
cette situation quand on le sait très
bien une majorité des français à
condition qu'ils soient volontaires
soient vaccinés
or quand on jette quand j'entends le
gouvernement en france et et quand je
vois la stratégie européenne
j'ai entendu le commissaire bretons
encore ce matin sur certaines antennes
dire on continue à on a assez de vaccins
on en aura assez on n'a pas besoin de
faire appel à d'autres vaccins c'est un
peu la vie complètement suicidaire
j'avais je vends jean mariani les grands
esprits par contre je vous couper pour
ça thierry breton alors c'était pas les
autres absences étaient manifestement le
vaccin ce contenu vers russe qui lui
posait des des petits problèmes
existentiels 1 les russes qui paraît-il
ont du mal à produire leurs vaccins
alors que c'est vrai que là on aime ou
on aime pas la russie peu importe c'est
lé premier à produire ce vaccin est
qu'il faudrait peut-être aidé
comment vous expliquez cette forme en
quoi de d'arrogance de provocation dans
la communication de l'idéologie je vais
être extrêmement dur mais c'est la
réalité
au niveau européen on fait passer les a
priori idéologiques avant la santé des
européens
je veux dire aujourd'hui il y aura
peut-être si les acomptes la campagne de
vaccination continue
pas fonctionner des européens vont
mourir parce que tout simplement
l'europe fait passer ses a priori c'est
a priori politique avant la santé des
français
franchement les vaccins moi je me moque
de savoir s'ils sont russes cubage
chinois nord-coréen
le problème c'est de savoir s'ils sont
efficaces or aujourd'hui tout prouve que
le vaccin russe comme d'autres vaccins
ont prouvé leur efficacité
voilà pourquoi on refuse et en plus
pourquoi en france parce que là aussi on
a un a priori idéologiques de monsieur
macron qui consiste à dire l'europe
l'europe l'europe mais les italiens ont
négocié avec les russes et sont prêts à
produire ce vaccin en italie madame
merkel vous le savez à envoyer une
mission en allemagne pour discuter avec
les autorités russes pour produire le
vaccin en russie à la même point de
pardon pour produire ce vaccin en
allemagne et elle a même ajouté
si l'union européenne refuse de mollo
qu'est ce vaccin est bien les autorités
allemandes le ferons homologué voilà et
pourquoi en france on continue à être
bloquée sur l'europe l'europe l'europe
l'europe a montré son inefficacité
voilà je pense que cette crise est en
train de se diviser sur ce vaccin russe
justement écouter l'europe est surtout
en train de d'avoir deux sortes de pays
ceux qui pensent d'abord à la santé de
leurs concitoyens
les italiens les hongrois et d'autres
qui disent et les allemands qui disent
voilà aujourd'hui on manque de vaccins
il faut en trouver partout
eh bien oui à la commande de européenne
mais oui il faut la compléter par
exemple avec les vaccins russe thierry
mariani quand on voit que sur le tarmac
des aéroports allemands où on voit des
avions décollé avec à l'intérieur des
vaccins biotech puisqu'ils ont inventé
produit avec pfizer qu'on les envoie à
dubaï et que des jeunes de 25 ans se
font vacciner
on se dit pas un petit peu que l'europe
s'est fait avoir dans cette affaire
l'europe a été nul je crois qu'il faut
dire la vérité
l'europe a montré que c'était d'abord
est à commander les vaccins beaucoup
trop tard parce que la bureaucratie
bruxelloise est hallucinante
voilà l'europe a voulu négocier jusqu'au
bout alors que des pays ont compris que
il valait mieux dépenser quelques
millions de plus pour les vaccins tout
de suite parce qu'en réalité c'était des
économies par cependant ne bloquez pas
le la vie économique du pays et trois
pour dépenser quelques millions de plus
dans les vaccins
c'était quelques milliards de moins
dépenser pour les subventions et et en
plus je le répète maintenant quand
j'entends le commissaire breton qui est
pourtant un homme intelligent il nous
explique qu'on n'a pas besoin d'autres
vaccins moi je vois en provence côte
d'azur des médecins des mères qui me
disent on est prêts à vacciner mais on a
pas de vaccin voilà et donc faire passer
c'est a priori idéologiques et
gravissime en plus pardonnez moi mais
c'est des a priori idéologiques
véritablement uniquement dirigé contre
la russie
parce que quand on nous explique
pourquoi coche de monsieur navalni en
prison on ne peut pas commander les
vaccins
ça gêne personne que monsieur khashoggi
a été découpé en rondelles par l'arabie
saoudite
quand on achète son pétrole ça ne gêne
pas la politique du qatar quand on
achète son pétrole donc l'union
européenne fait de la morale fait les
droits de l'homme uniquement quand ça
les arrange
elle ferait mieux de s'occuper en
priorité la santé de ses concitoyens
je le répète le les retards que nous
prenons les choix politiques que nous
prenons en choisissant ces vaccins
risquent de coûter cher en vies humaines
thierry mariani dernière petite question
qui vous concerne indirectement est
d'ailleurs très directement le
gouvernement veut se conformer à l'avis
du conseil scientifique toujours lui
attendu au plus tard le 1er avril pour
décider du maintien ou pas des scrutins
départementales et régionales prévues
les 13 et 20 juin vous êtes d'ailleurs
entre parenthèses donné gagnant face à
renaud muselier si elle est réelle elle
la république en marche ne fusionne pas
en région paca votre avis sur ce report
écoutez si on peut se rendre chez son
cordonnier ou chez son coiffeur on peut
passer quelques minutes dans un bureau
de vote
les pays bas par exemple nous ont montré
il ya quelques jours qu'on pouvait tout
à fait faire une élection sans aucun
problème donc soyons sérieux passé deux
minutes dans un bureau de vote où on met
à disposition du gel et on respecte les
gestes barrière permettent tout à fait
voter d'ailleurs je constate qu'une
dizaine de présidents de conseils
régionaux on dit il faut arrêter de
reporter ces élections
alors après ça va être intéressant parce
que faut pas aussi être naïf je pense
que le rêve secret de monsieur macron
c'est que ces élections soient reportées
soit reporter pourquoi parce que dans ce
cas là ça permettra ça bloquera certains
partis comme les républicains qui ne
pourront pas désigner leur candidat
assez rapidement et puis ça évitera
aussi au parti de la république en
marche de se prendre probablement une
raclée monumentale parce que les
français ont compris une chose c'est que
pour gérer la crise a visiblement macron
sap a été un champion
merci thierry mariani député européen du
rassemblement national d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur arte france